bong et voilà ça y est tous des prêts
voilà à bonjour comment ça va moi je
vais très bien aujourd'hui je m'apprête
à passer une journée formidable
regardez d'abord je vais finir mon
tableau gemma palais j'ai mes pinceaux
j'ai mon cheval est bon ensuite venait
on y voir ensuite je vais faire de la
musique regarder ces les bidons de mon
orchestre
on va faire une musique guerre et là
c'est moi qui les composent et ici j'ai
la can et et mon chapeau haut de forme
pour faire là la petite danse que je
suis en train de mettre au point avec
julie après tout ça j'aurais sûrement
très fin alors j'ai apporté de quoi me
préparer un gloubi boulga fantastique à
papa nouveau papa mon papa me pourtant
c'est vraiment merveilleux
on est tellement bien dans cette île
personne ne vient vous déranger salle
états unis
bonjour julie tu fais de la peinture si
je lui qu'est ce que ça représente
comment tu ne vois pas je ne comprends
pas c'est l'île aux enfants pays de la
liberté
bien sûr excuses moi c'est évident ah la
la
les gentils cette jolie mais elle manque
un peu de jugement artistique
mais attention il a tous pam est bidon
voyons méchant juste devant mon coeur
que comment au juste au moment où je
peins l'îlot z'enfants pays de la
liberté
tu me prends la mienne je te prends quoi
ma liberté je ne peux même plus posé
quelques bidons ont les plus libres à
boom si tu le prends comme ça je te
laisse avec vous pour dommage est patent
discuter qu'est-ce que mais qu'est ce
que c'est tout ça devant ebano la
peinture en huit ans
yes man nous et ma peinture où ils sont
1 c'était toi casimir et ben j'aurais dû
m'en douter écoute tu va me prendre tout
ça est dû aller un petit peu plus loin
en mai comme un corps aussi
enfin on ne peut plus pas dire ce que
l'on veut à l'endroit où l'on veut quand
on veut
or un coot casimir puisque c'est aussi
important
je veux bien te laisser la place
quelques instants mais casimir je la
reprends dans un petit moment
d'accord bon allez donc à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a plus de liberté l'on sait qui
c'est incroyable comme bonjour casimir
bonjour factor pour sûr je suis je suis
épuisé je veux me reposer un peu sur le
banc va falloir que je pousse chapeau
quoi quoi quoi la main dans la paca ne
touchez pas à mon chapeau mais mes gars
calme mais bien enfin casimir mais je
veux me reposer car je vais je vais me
mettre de l'autre côté du banc ne te
fâche pas en attendant l'appel non plus
vous allez abîmée toutes les bonnes
choses que j'ai préparé pour mon
excellent gloubiboulga mais je suis très
fatigué 15 émergent en ligne et sa
famille dont il faut que je puisse
vendre mes balles aux jambes sous le nom
que je pourrais faire et quand on perd
ce n'est plus possible
silence je ne suis plus libre je vais
défendre les libertés de sept-îles
[Musique]
atop on ne va pas en bidons 1
mais je viens mon kiosque non non pas de
discussion circulait circulait à mon
facteur ne va pas au banc enfin que je
me reprends que j'ai mis enfin je jouais
mon n'y a pas de casimir je ne suis par
casimir allez circulez circulait vous
avez en mai non vraiment casimir exagère
pour protéger sa liberté à lui il embête
tout le monde
il s'est nommé lui-même agents de police
nous faisons tout semblant lui obéir
mais je lui réserve une bonne petite
place à antoine on ne va pas en ballon
interdite oui monsieur l'agent dites moi
monsieur l'agent white qu'est ce que
c'est eh bien ça doit être lourd à la
longue votre balade très lourd et bien
si on accrochait un ballon au bout ils
sont plus légers
nous ça ça c'est une bonne idée à harry
vitement que cherchait un oui monsieur
l'agent oui malheureusement le chevalet
de casimir m'empêche d'atteindre mes
balles au à oui oui c'est bien dommage
13e l'argent vous n'avez pas soif avec
ce soleil et votre pétition la terre si
près j'aimerais bien une citronnade avec
quelques rondelles de cornichons à ces
bêtes écouter parce que j'ai tout ça
dans mon casque mais les bidons de quasi
viande empêche le passé - pourriez vous
asseoir un moment sur le banc ça vous
répondrai volontiers
hélas toutes les affaires de casimir
vous interdise de vous asseoir sur le
banc
bon bah tant pis
bonjour mademoiselle bonjour messieurs
jean au jour de ce photographe bonjour
que se passe-t-il si je peux leur donner
c'est bien sous prétexte de protéger sa
liberté à lui casimir a planté son
chevalet juste devant des ballons et
c'est bidon devant monk aspects et
toutes sortes d'objets des deux côtés du
bon les illustres pid coire stupide
ah oui monsieur l'agent ce kazimiyah
comme vous l'appelez non y compris la
liberté de chacun s'arrête
lorsqu'elle gêne
celle des autres vous avez compris ça à
vous monsieur l'agent oui oui oui
eh bien vous êtes donc d'accord avec moi
pour dire que casino est stupide
n'est ce pas ben ouais voilà
[Musique]